Building an app that uses Google
Services generally follows this pattern.
First, you'll create a Google API
client, and on that client
you'll specify the services that
you want to use the desired API.
In this case, it's location services.
Now, the activity that hosts this
client will need to be extended for
the appropriate callbacks and listeners.
The first of these is
GoogleApiClientConnectionCallbacks.
These allow you to code against
events in the Api Client itself,
such as connecting, or
disconnecting from the services.
The next is the
GoogleApiClient.OnConnectionFailedListe-
ner.
This can alert you when
the connection drops,
so that you can handle failures to
connect to Google Apis Gracefully.
Specifically for location services,
you'll also need the location listener.
And as its name suggests,
it listens to location updates so
that you can respond to
them in your application.
You then connect your clients and
wait for the on connected call back.
Now for this app, you're going to
have code that makes a request for
your current location.
You put that in
the OnConnected Callback, and
this sets up another Callback
called OnLocationChanged.
And when the OnLocationChange Callback
fires, it will contain your location
information so that you can capture
details such as the latitude, and
update your UI accordingly.